it sorry is good sex not what makes you
feel good if you're lacking out your
feeling then you're gonna deem it as
good sex regardless if so yeah I think
what everyone deems as good sex is some
people say that oh when you have sex
with the first but someone with the
first time it's not necessarily great
but as you get to know each other's body
it becomes better so then I don't think
you need to be exposed so much you just
have to understand each other and have
that connection so don't you think it's
better to do that with one person and
then have multiple experiences then yeah
yeah 100 yeah yeah I don't think you
need to sleep with many people no
definitely not and in terms of like a
sexual connection as well like you could
have sex with someone who's amazing in
bed
um and maybe it's not treating you as
good as someone else or that you have a
stronger chemistry with and he's not as
good as bad but I think as a woman you
will emotionally connect with a person
who's not as good yeah you want to go
out of the Good Wood
I think we will I think we will Overlook
that when a girl gets hypnotized
is it the same for men or no like do men
um if men slept with left less women
would they be oh is that yeah
statistically
um so the the best outcomes is when
they're both virgins okay so that's
that's one thing I think sometimes like
people gloss over however
um a man that slept with around eight or
nine if I remember correctly
um Partners versus three is happier in
his marriage okay so actually men's
happiness goes up at some point rather
than down when they've slept with more
people and I think it kind of goes back
to like like a lot of things like I
guess red pill trees are kind of known
in society like before but they would
say men would go sew their Wild Oats and
then go get a wife
but yeah the more people a woman slept
with decreases I have a question for the
panel how many times have you fallen in
love
once once once once
I don't know if I have you know I don't
think I have evil um
I'm full in love before
um
I feel like I've experienced different
types of Love though you see you haven't
fallen in love no I have you have okay
yeah but
there's one time two times oh I was 16
and she was like 20.
she was my substitute teacher
literally my age in life I think it's
infatuation yeah she came into my life
today she might still be able to get me
make sure she looked the same I don't
know
you know the idea of uh you fell in love
with the idea
the way I envisioned her like she was my
queen
the first time I got drunk and [__] they
say that man like it's kind of weird
like every girl that they've been in
love with they kind of like love them
forever in like a weird way that women
won't understand because we only love
one guy at a time that's right say that
again it's like I've heard this I'm I'm
butchering it but basically like men can
love multiple women at the same time and
so like there'll be a lot of times it's
a common story like oh he's still in
love with his high school girlfriend or
high school or something and like it's
an archetype that I've just heard over
and over again and it's like men when
they fall in love with someone it's like
they're in love with them forever and
like women won't understand that but
then what about the idea that a woman
who's had multiple partners is still
loving her ex well that's that's because
that was the best she could do
so like I mean historically women ended
up with the best guy they could be with
because otherwise their husband would
get killed and she'd get taken by the
best guy I mean that's why women this is
an uncomfortable this is an
uncomfortable truth but the number one
requested
um like
Rico he had a male only fans model on
the show and the number one thing women
request is grape that's great wow yeah
that's crazy yeah and I and like like
why do women like being like choked why
do women like yo it's because like
biologically they they kind of ah I
don't know
why do girls like the handmaid's tale
when women love that show
my adult experience the woman who has
been the most dominant and successful
Mexican at work is the one who wants to
be utterly dominated at home yeah okay
so I think I'm like that I like I like
to feel like someone else is in control
yeah right but it's because I feel like
in my whole life I've had to be in
charge and I don't like it so I'd like
to come home and know that I can put all
my man could just chokey no
oh well you talk about sexually I was
talking about sexually oh because well
because that's what you were saying
right you said about early months for
modeling that yeah yeah it's like like
so so I was saying like women want to be
with the best the guy they could
historically because we we would be but
now it's it's not like that and so like
if a girl experiences experience as a
guy that's like too high like she'll
think about him forever and you and you
all know you have a friend that always
runs back to that same EX
we were talking about twin flames before
you know you know the thing about like
the love and being a love thing and
always have enough for that person I
think that goes for men and women they
you know they're saying they say the
first love Cuts deep and I I or the
first love is very deep and I think for
men and women because like we've been
having this conversation the other day
that the first guy that goes with right
that she basically has her everything
like the sex with him and emotional or
whatever right almost a lot of guys
after that are almost a different like
an archetype of that guy because it's
like the first love is almost like an
imprint it's like it's like the first
the I've heard this song guy had a
theory on this and I'm curious if the
girls think this is true so first first
three guys that a girl sleeps with the
best sass out of the three that's her
type forever
I think your type changes over time as
you evolve over time right like you
learn more about yourself what you like
what you don't like would you would you
say um the older you've gotten like how
is your type change you go for like the
bad boys you know like the guys that
used to treat me like [__] and then as I
got older I was like oh they treat me
like [__] so like my change has
completely changed like I go for
different looks complete I go for more
personality you know like what do you
mean so like the the sexual part like
comparatively between the good guy and
the bad guy as your as your preference
in bed change as well
okay yeah I feel like don't you feel
like you can only get y Zone all of this
stuff by experience so did you have to
date different type of guys to know what
you don't want 100 yeah yeah
that's but see this is like the common
company of men is that women give their
best years to guys that are bad and then
expect them to pick up the pieces after
when people say that um
I think my best years well forget about
the your beliefs of Virgin and all of
that but that's not my boys
my traits and my personality and how I
might carrying myself and everything I'm
a better woman now yeah yeah but yeah
okay so yes to yourself if you're basing
it if you're basing it on
um me being a single mom and all of that
stuff then yes no matter what I do I may
not but if someone was to take the
chance to get to know me now and got to
know me a man get to know me back then
he would prefer the woman he would be
more willing to get to listen to hear me
out now than he would back then and
that's even when I was with no kids
single and whatever and you you might be
like a more agreeable woman now would
you say that's true I'm a what agreeable
like a real ball kind of goes with
femininity like maybe you're more
feminine now oh 100 yeah and so like
that might be true but like what gets
you in the door is like looks Youth and
kids are no kids because because it's
like like a guy has a checklist of
things here yeah 100 and so it's like
you're not in the same doors no well I
would like I think I think there's
qualities that attract a man and there's
qualities that people man yeah I know
correct me if I'm wrong I think you're
saying the qualities that you have that
will keep in mind now is superior than
what you had before yeah but I think
what almost they're saying is that maybe
the qualities to attract the man maybe
it's a little bit lower than it was
before but I do think that a man will
compromise on the
attractive qualities for the right I
mean I don't say like all hope like my
my sister was a single mother and she
got married too I would say she did
better than her baby daddy but like I I
think it was an exception it's not the
rule why would you I would add that men
are probably more likely to tolerate bad
characteristics
for women to have less baggage
because it's like if I had to if I had
to look at it comparatively would I take
a woman with a child over a woman that
was more problematic problematic but no
child I probably go for the one that's
more problematic just because at least I
can make the mistakes with her instead
of having to carry on someone else's
baggage do you feel like you can the the
quote unquote things that you don't like
you know you feel like that's more
malleable whereas like you're saying
like the child like the child's there
like that's it yeah yeah because that's
something irreversible that I can't
change would you say the same thing
as in what would I take more problematic
with no child I'll be honest if I was
looking to like say I don't have kids
now I would
I'll try to shoot
but also I would take I would take the
more problematic if I feel that we could
work together I would but I feel like a
lot of men surprise themselves like I
feel like sometimes as well like you
don't know what you would do until
you're in that situation
I'll put my I'll put my hands up right
I've dated single months before and
they dream about it in single girls oh
single mothers are lit they [__] know
what's the difference
especially if they have sons yeah
because well they take care of the
taking care of the nurturing
you're so submissive yeah
they know they have less leverage yeah
for that reason because I know
intrinsically that the only reason
you're that way is because of the
mistakes you've made okay so what's
wrong with that I don't want that why I
don't want it but why well I I pick
yeah
car analogy is coming again
all the qualities you want in a woman
she has it but just because she has
experience or a child that's not a small
thing and a child that's what you're
saying you won't maybe yeah no way but
you date her I'm a Nigerian man as well
you're a Nigerian uh no you're not damn
okay
I think I think what this highlights is
that
how women see a woman with a child and
how men look at it is completely
different like where we're so easy with
being with getting with a guy that has a
child
mm-hmm the expenses don't fall on us
yeah
so I was going to say that about how
women could maybe not initially I don't
think they would aim to go for a guy
with a child but I think if they fell in
love and got to know a guy
yeah
Pockets yeah well it's an attraction
trigger for women so like men are
biologically predispositioned to be
repulsed by other people's kids that's
why they have this reaction to it wow
yeah because historically what would
they do they'd take the women and kill
the kids
like if one it would be tribes so if one
tribe conquered the other tribe it goes
back to what I was saying earlier like
where women would end up with the best
male yes so if one tribe conquered the
other tribe they would take the fertile
women okay they would take the the they
might they might take a girls if she's
old enough but they kill the kids
right but and a big reason of that they
had to yeah it's not it's not good it's
just not yeah I think it's a big reason
that comes back to what you said is as a
man if you're going to choose a woman
who has kids then the responsibility of
the child often falls on you and the
truth is like I said we're selfish by
Design right the reason that we kill the
kids back in the day was because as a
man he it was his job to put his life on
the line for the family and best believe
if he spent his life online for his
family he's doing it for his own kin and
not someone else and women like men with
kids because historically if he had a
kid that was a sign of pre-selection he
could take care of other women yeah it's
a sign of responsibility actually also
another fun fact is
um felons have 30 more kids than
non-felons so when women say they like
nice guys cap
[Laughter]
okay I'm gonna take a tank I'm gonna
read the super chats okay guys
um also as many of you know I was just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible